look I'm in my mid-40s and I can tell
you that you can get and maintain very
healthy testosterone levels without trt
if you do the right things the behaviors
the nutrition all the other stuff this
is often not discussed or overlooked in
the discussion about testosterone
therapy and performance enhancing drugs
low enough testosterone or prevents
people from sleeping exercise Social
connection Etc so I do want to
acknowledge that I actually think it's
worse than that I think that they simply
don't understand and don't care and then
they end up with issues like joint pain
memory issues and severe drops in libido
but it actually shuts down the sexual
desire and aggression never get to
reproduce in fact they never even get to
have sex at all and we don't often think
about that but testosterone plays a
powerful role in determining which
members of a given species will get to
reproduce which ones of that species
will actually get access to females that
the higher levels of testosterone
correlate with access to females the
females are detecting which males have
high testosterone and selecting them but
it's actually more so that the males
that have higher testosterone forage
further and will fight harder for the
females So today we're going to talk
about how you can optimize the ratios
depending on your particular life goals
because the ratio of estrogen and
testosterone in every individual has
profound influence on feelings of
well-being feelings of optimism feelings
of anxiety or lack of anxiety on
reproduction on sexual behavior
independent of reproduction they are
profoundly powerful molecules and we all
make these molecules to some degree or
another but there are also important
behavioral tools supplementation tools
as well as prescription drugs that can
impact ratios of testosterone and
estrogen in really powerful ways so
we're going to cover all of that in
males it's interesting to point out the
testosterone is promoting seeking of sex
but it's also estrogen in males that's
important for libido if estrogen levels
are brought too low then men will
completely lose the their libido so
testosterone promotes sex-seeking
Behavior and the real question then is
does sex itself promote testosterone and
the answer is somewhat complicated but
the short version is yes and sex has
multiple stages so there's the physical
act of sex there's the seeking of sex
and then there's orgasm and ejaculation
now it's important to distinguish
between these because whether or not sex
itself increases testosterone depends on
whether or not the male ejaculates but
then after ejaculation there's a release
of prolactin and prolactin actually sets
the refractory period in males during
which he can't have sex again so there
are studies showing that sexual behavior
itself can increase testosterone men who
observe sex so I guess this would be
observing pornography they had increases
in testosterone that were very modest of
about 10 percent whereas when people
participated in sex they actually did
this study where people had blood draws
and they had real sex with their
Partners they had 70 percent increases
in testosterone so there are increases
in testosterone that are quite
significant during the physical act of
sex and far less so during observing sex
whether or not ejaculation adjusts
testosterone levels and it turns out
that sex and ejaculation itself does not
reduce testosterone levels although it
will increase prolactin levels for the
reasons I described a moment ago however
abstinence or sex without ejaculation
for a week or more will increase
testosterone levels up to 400 percent so
the answer is actually complicated it's
not straightforward what it means is
that sex itself increases testosterone
however abstinence also increases
testosterone even further so it's a
nuanced answer and you have to
understand that Nuance if you want to
understand how certain behaviors impact
hormones and how hormones impact those
behaviors one of the quickest ways to
boost someone's testosterone is to have
them achieve a win repeated failures
take testosterone levels lower than they
would be otherwise if you want to
optimize testosterone and estrogen you
need to get your light viewing Behavior
correct but it means getting anywhere
from two to ten minutes of bright light
exposure in your eyes early in the day
getting increases in dopamine that are
going to promote the production of
testosterone and estrogen to healthy
levels viewing Bright Light Within the
first hour of waking whether or not from
artificial light or ideally from
sunlight has these powerful effects on
sleep and wakefulness but we have to
return to this if you want to understand
how light can impact hormones because
hormones light and dopamine have a very
close-knit relationship so much so that
your light viewing Behavior can actually
have a direct effect on hormone levels
and fertility it can have a direct
effect on hormone levels and libido it
can have a direct effect on hormone
levels and your ability to feel quickly
so bright light early in the day and
throughout the day is great view as much
bright light ideally sunlight as you can
getting a lot of light in your eyes is
not just about adjusting your sleep wake
rhythms it's also about optimizing your
sex steroid hormones and avoiding bright
light in the middle of the night is not
just about not disrupting your sleep
it's also about optimizing the sex
steroid hormones and things like ice
baths and cold showers can have positive
effects on the sex steroid hormones both
testosterone mainly in males and
estrogen mainly in females you're
cooling the neurons that control
vasoconstriction and vasodilation and
shutting down the entry of blood or at
least reducing it and hormones into the
gonad then stimulate the gonad to
release more testosterone or would
stimulate the gonad to release more
estrogen if you want to increase
testosterone weight training with heavy
loads but not to failure seems to be the
best supported at least scientifically
supported solution to that when moving
heavy loads but not to failure that has
to provide some sort of feedback signal
either to the gonad to produce more
testosterone or is increasing the
activity of receptors in the body now it
may not raise your testosterone levels
as high as you want but it's definitely
taking things in the correct direction
okay so now let's talk about the role of
specific compounds some of which many of
which can be taken in supplementation
form in order to optimize sex Droid
hormones and again I just want to
emphasize that I'm not suggesting anyone
take anything or stop taking anything
this is purely for informational
purposes but some of the data on these
is quite striking and impressive it's
very clear that certain collections of
nutrients are useful for promoting
testosterone and estrogen production in
their proper ratios and those things are
what I would call the sort of Usual
Suspects vitamin D which is important
for so many biological functions
including endocrine functions zinc
magnesium
Etc I personally have supplemented with
zinc magnesium and vitamin D for years
now for people that aren't getting
prescribed trt but want the increase in
testosterone they're these plant
compounds like Tonga Ali so Tonga Ali
about 400 milligrams per day has the
effect of raising free testosterone and
overall testosterone by about 100 to 200
points and another one which is very
interesting it's a Nigerian shrub called
fedogia agrestus and it mimics
luteinizing hormone which is the hormone
that comes out of the hypothalamus that
stimulates the testes if you got those
in your ovaries if you've got those to
make more testosterone or estrogen and
so those two herbal supplements together
can give a significant boost in free
inactive testosterone who said Tongan
Ali can give you 100 to 200. how about
that what does the other one give you
fedojia is usually taken at about 600
milligrams the most dramatic effect I've
ever seen was somebody who had is
testosterone down in the low twos or I
think it was like low twos and it he got
it up to the 700 range which but that's
it but that's an outlier right most
people are going to see about a three to
four hundred Point increase so Dojo will
actually make the testes grow it's a
it's a noticeable difference everybody
wants that